the host of the Pat McAfee show and as
well as a Thursday night football
analyst for ESPN the one the only
America's Sweetheart
himself Pat McAfee Horry Pat Rich I'm
feeling good you know and I'm thankful
that a national media member has echoed
the sentiments of all the people on the
internet who are saying that I implored
and willed the Titans to be great this
year and here we are to going into the
divisional round talking about the
Titans potentially ending the dynasty in
New England it all started right there
and I'm happy that you've taken that
stand because you know a lot of people
have been saying it you're just the
first one to do it on national since you
know what Pat look III know and I've
known for quite some time you're just a
factor you're a factor even when you
don't think you're gonna be a factor you
but wind up being a factor and and
that's just about it I'm only spitting
truth you know well I'll tell you what
though this Tennessee Titans thing has
been fun to watch Marcus Mariota take a
seat we're bringing in Ryan Tannehill
out from underneath Adam GaSe his
failure umbrella
Michael Vrabel says in an offseason
interview with bus and with the boys
he's willing to cut off his babymaker
for another Super Bowl that whole team
takes on his identity they got a running
back who's six foot 12 the runs a for
four yep I mean they are a fun team to
watch but I think they might be running
into a buzz saw rich we had a good one
lined up this weekend for divisional
round well Pat when I was starting the
NFL Network a back in in O 3 where I
guess you were just coming out of high
school getting ready to piss Rich
Rodriguez off as much as you did the the
rivalry for the Ravens was Ravens Titans
there's ray on one side and there's
Eddie George and another and McNair
gives hands the ball off to Eddie who's
running his way towards Ray Lewis and it
was on man and it's I have a feeling
we're gonna see some sort of throwback
like that the weather's supposed to be
nasty and raining on Saturday night I
cannot wait for that one man well I mean
I think just the thought of these two
offensive lines have done such a good
job and I know that football be
this error rate attack with fantasy
football numbers in fantasy football
points becoming the equivalent to rules
being changed and everything like that
but with what Harbaugh did just
completely flipping his entire team to
go all-in on a special talent like Lamar
Jackson building up the tight end room
building up the offensive line get a
deep threat and then that defense by
bringing in Marcus Peters it's just
classic old school football and Vrabel
and the Titans and the boys play the
exact same way we're in for a
slobberknocker a slugfest and in 2003 I
was a sophomore in high school I was
just a little baby I don't even think I
take the football in a game yet by that
point but whenever you talk about the
old school yes Ray Lewis Eddie Jordan
you're talking about great back then
rich and that's how long you've been a
voice of the NFL no stop it well you
know and then the first Super Bowl we
covered the co-mvp s were Peyton Manning
and Steve McNair and I mean and those
were the days again the AFC South had
just been born in the AFC North had the
Ravens in my remember we were all just
bummed
the Titans Ravens games that we love
twice a year we're not going to have it
now it's like running a football is what
it's all about now and being physical
and running downhill you know and and
and that's why I love watching Derek
Henry do what he does and then the fact
that variables 101 and Dunn's the the
Brady Belichick Patriots like that is
something else what are you in turns
what do you think he's gonna do Patrick
well have you ever seen somebody in a
more beautiful position of leverage and
Tom Brady right now exactly I I don't
think I've ever seen anything at all
perfectly he's speaking very highly of
craft of Belichick of the Patriots
obviously they're the greatest dynasty
in the history of sports not just in the
NFL but him telling Kraft before the
season that after 20 years he would like
to control his own destiny and then how
the year went whatever he was talking to
his wide receivers about being something
that they can't just flip a switch and
be I need you to be faster I need you to
be quicker I need you to be more
explosive I think Tom Brady is at a
point right
now where he has accomplished everything
by all accounts the greatest football
player of all time six Super Bowl rings
very wealthy he's at a point now where I
think he's gonna tell the Patriots
listen I need more weapons I need better
personnel or I'm gonna potentially test
the waters in an NFL where I think 26
teams would be very much willing us for
him to be their head their starting
quarterback and I think he's in a good
spot I think he deserves it I'm excited
to kind of watch it all unfold but if
you look up there Joe judge is out Kyle
van Noy probably out Tom Brady
potentially out is it the end I will set
it here for them are you calling Joe
Judge a domino that's tumbling is that
what you just called him is that what
you just refer to you don't mean we
watch the games this year defense and
special teams won them their games yeah
in the special teams Matthew Slater who
is an animal just in bethel very good
their punter their rookie punter and
their kickers have been an issue but I
think special teams is a massive part of
their success and that's why Bill
Belichick loves the special teams aspect
of the game so much Joe judge I think
it's gonna be a great coach at the
Giants but you get that big brain out of
there you lose they annoy potentially an
Tom this is I mean this is my childhood
basically coming to an end this isn't
that situation for everybody well you
were in a spot where obviously that you
were in the middle of a ton of
slobberknocker x' to use a phrase
yourself coats and colts and Patriots
and I had Tony Dungy on in our number
one and I'm saying that for two reasons
one to drop the name of a Pro Football
Hall of Famer in what normally would be
an organic way to also he mentioned the
Colts as the best spot for Brady do you
think on any way possible on this green
earth knowing the Colts organization as
well as you do that that's gonna happen
or what happened do you think that I'll
tell you what you walk around
Indianapolis you don't have to go far to
ask somebody if they like Tom Brady and
they'll say they hate him I mean the
courts in Patriots and he's gonna
remember the Indianapolis Colts weren't
that big of a thing in Indianapolis it
was the Pacers it was the Indy 500 and
then one Manning got here it became a
football town I mean Peyton Manning
flipped this town into being a football
town because of the incredible run of
success
but any time they had failures it was
normally because of one handsome man who
went to Michigan and played quarterback
for the Patriots and there's a lot of
heat for that guy here I think a lot of
X players are not the biggest fan of him
or the thought of him being a coach but
if he was to come to the coats and do
well I think everybody would love him
immediately I think it's not something
that many Colts fans would desire I
don't think anybody's out there
picketing for him to become a Colt but I
think if you have a chance to have the
greatest of all time on your team I
would assume everybody would come around
with some success there's no doubt about
it Pat because I mean look at I heart
Yankee fan I grew up in Staten Island
New York I hated Wade Boggs
I thought all he did was just play wall
ball off of the Fenway Park remonster
and try and get his way to the Hall of
Fame with cheap doubles and cheap
triples and singles and then he rides a
horse back for the Yankee pinstripes to
win a championship in 96 and I love the
guy I mean that's that's a fact these
are things that fans would do and it
worked for Vinatieri too didn't it yeah
I mean Vinatieri comes over from the
Patriots to the Colts they want a Super
Bowl that first year now they're not
granted this last year hasn't been
perfect for vegetarians Airy is loved
here but loved here Tom Brady obviously
the face of that franchise that is
disappointed the Indianapolis humans on
a regular basis but if he gets here has
success embraces the public great place
to raise a family you know great place
to raise a family I know he doesn't have
a lot of money your dollar goes a long
way here in Indianapolis even gizelle
and also the cz 12 clinic would do great
here in Indiana if he was ever to think
about it but as long as he has a little
bit of success they would love him here
but any general manager in the NFL would
take you a conversation with Tom Brady
on the drop of a hat and I think Tom
knows that and I can't wait to see it
all kind of unfold
McAfee here on the Rich Eisen show so
your Super Bowl would be what right now
you got eight teams left what do you
predict where does it stand right now
and who would you take it's different oh
I think it's gonna be passes Niners okay
in the NFC obviously I think it's gonna
be Ravens Chiefs I think the Chiefs
might win by 50 against the Texans not
because deshaun Watson isn't incredible
and JJ Watt is inspiring and does all
that I just think they were down 16 zip
to the bills if you get down at all to
the Chiefs I think
and II read in that beautiful mind will
step on the throttle and step on your
throat and pull it away let's patch up
the homes
I like the Raven beating the Titans in a
close one
I think oh I don't know I don't know I
have to see how the Ravens play this
weekend two weeks off for Lamar Jackson
in that offense I think it's going to
rest up the old line I'd like to see how
they perform this weekend to give you an
exact quote but I think it's going to be
Chiefs Ravens Niners Packers let's have
a classic shootout on both sides and see
what the hell happens where is the good
one I think I think the NFL got it right
here now the Saints being out is a
little bit worrisome in the NFC side I
thought I thought it was gonna be sank
Niners each and I thought that was gonna
be cool but for me I think we got it
right and I think this round is gonna be
a beautiful one well you know the Ravens
are in for it cuz not only do the Titans
come to town off a big win but they have
the best weapon in the playoffs don't
they Pat yeah I mean Bret turn on a boy
here's a guy that when the ball touches
his hand you know electricity is about
to come from his right foot
I've been saying it for a couple years
Bret turn was the most underrated and
underappreciated punter to ever come
into the NFL he put on a shell affair in
New England but don't put a pass Sam
Cooke and Justin Tucker also do well up
there no no we got a big for the brain
game in the air no doubt we do and let's
be honest your pet we're all talking
about how Brady's not gonna retire off
the pick six how did the pick six get
set up you tell me pet how did that ball
get on the one-yard line you know a man
named Bret turns and strong all-out rush
nobody back Julian Edelman had to pick
up the gunner and he went ahead brought
out his wedge and down that thing on the
half yard line and said hey Tom you got
15 seconds pal good luck not on my watch
nobody can describe a punt quite like
you Pat nobody can take the words in the
English language and and and fire them
together link them together so lyrically
to describe the punt quite like you and
I also include the term piss missile in
that I uh you know what I'm saying
hey hey you piss missile with something
now that wasn't a piston I have a little
bit of touch but it just feels like it's
just butter coming off your foot
and you hear that in a crowd you hear
the whoo you know that you're in for a
good one whether not being great
Baltimore is not beautiful for the brand
but Jim Brett turn and say I'm coking
the boys we'll get through it but yeah I
love a good pun and I knew
whenever I decided to retire and get
into the media after being the punter of
the decade I knew that when I got into
the media the special teams had not been
talked about enough and I knew that so
much magic was happening if I could just
talk about it a little bit the people
would respond and they have rich in
drove no doubt god bless you because I
thought I was all alone on that fact and
then you were the cavalry that came do
you get an award for being punter of the
decade is there like a trophy for that
no trophy I'm hoping for a championship
belt just walk around with pretty good
title almost put it as my Twitter bio
didn't want to flex too hard well I'll
flex for you Pat you started this
conversation by saying that I'm the
national voice the first one to talk
about you and what you did in Tennessee
you sir are a national voice yourself I
mean you got your show on his own
Westwood won congratulations on Westwood
once indicating you you are a national
you look at you you're a national voice
Pat you are there's too much of me rich
right now and I've been showing up in
new cities because CBS sports radio just
picked us up as well that's right
everyone go off every once in a while
I'll get a tweet from somebody that has
never heard of me before and they'll
meet me and they'll be like slow down
you're talking damn it slow down your
speedier voice I'm sure it's good but it
sounds disgusting
no it's been nice getting introduced to
a lot of new people a real fun time god
bless you Pat let's chat again soon okay
man hey I'll see if that was the Super
Bowl probably you're the blent we have a
good one do we come on our show too long
oh man so yeah let's let's get together
the Super Bowl come on come on my show
how about a vice-versa about a
home-and-home what do you think well
usually your Super Bowl lineup is so big
I can't crack the code but now getting
an opportunity to be a part of that I
would love to
go on your show down there would
obviously love to have the voice of the
NFL on my show doesn't make some magic
down there and South Beach and hopefully
you know not stop by two T's will do it
Patrick will chat again soon I'll see
you soon
Hey right dude right back at you that
PAC mcafee show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app